[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さん
まあ200円
他にあったら
me 考えます
ございません
コンビニへ&がコーヒーのが変わっ
このほかに発展
7分ん
今日はそんなお話からサーブです
私はに
御喋りの20秒を群を抜くに入れ af
マライアの作品活動もなきゃっ
願う
これ実際に活動した裏の一つになります
安宅水1000来ないよーございます
両親もありません
このような村で
あるお母さんが
私のところ子どもを抱えながらいい
os で子供ら死ぬかもしれん
1,010円
いや前
皆さんだったの
いいよしろもうしていただければと思います
あげると言う
あげないん
ねん
私の回答は後者の
国が無になれば
他のお母さんにもあり
まだ
それが御本人が書いていなかったのか
そのお母さんが
私ができることっていうのはお金を上げることではない
今だ予防
する方向を変えることだっ
いうことでおかあさん
というのか
自分の中ではこれん
じゃあ簡単に100円
ありで言えば登録が望めます
で泥をも恥ずか
程度もこう言う
ものすごい
ぐらいにもう一度
からん
私の今のであれば
こういった例を少しでも減らす
そのために継続できるような改善も混んでたら改善できる
首を作ることが必要だと言う
なぜ咲き方な事例が便利だった
そのような場合以下のような問題点があります
病院までのアクセスが可能
その間になくないですか
または待ち時間
を使うと言うなっ
4時間を時間を読んでます
その間になる
まだ医療費が違った
病院に行くのをためらってしまう
仕様はくれです
たとえ病院にかぶりついたとしても
次はようになってい
これらの問題に入った
実績運は
目の前にあるのでアクセスも0ん
待ち時間があるん
いざに良いのか
のギグ3
日本発祥
300年前いる時代から吐くん
このように箱の中に行く使う釣りを得ておきます
そして家の方に微笑んでいた
月の扱いないためで使える言うなっ
4杯目2カップアップに支払うようなので
どうよお金がなくてもいいですかよ
これアメリカのもう孫文毎月お金が得られるわけではない
本当にこれが日本から発症したモデルが本当に機能するのかということで実際に打って
風情が発射されなければでん
なぜ日本でデブすると
内定がない
入っているこの
インフラが店
第5分
入ってるんですよない
ようなのせいですか
なかなか病院までのアクセス過多
さらにないこと今の日本のような株価
上置き薬の営業マンがこのさぶっ
海を県勢がじゃない
まぁ色々というのは帰っ先生とがあるので私たち
っくなっています
保険制度ないんだ
いよいんだん
こういった置きブスに
運休して入っていた
小野さん
まあね
ことからもあり方へ
荻野吸ったら
不二才を描こうで授業方法
スタンツました
何言っ
かぷ様があります
このように
担当者ベンバーガー
家族の声を金券
の方になっている
思った
[拍手]
ブースにのタイダイの縁となりません
似ていて
君たちで自分の健康をケアすることができ
使ってもし効果がなければ数に病院から
そういったプリアージュ親父
さらにこの
うづりを置くことで量が二時間になります
自分立つ気をすることができます
水を使わないため何度も予防すればいい
こういった教育も私です
ただ先ほど申しました通り
日本課長300円前10歳から
の群れん
これをアフリカ版
現代版で支えていこうということ
介護の
6日版っていうのはね
ホンダと学校
アフリカではアッコなります
また失点ないして
マライアのは
来ないんですけども
あくりかではたらエラー
脂肪の神のゾーイ必ず入っ
そういったものに対してね
次の目ではなくてまえよ献茶っていうキットなども私たちは10
さらに現在は
300年前の江戸時代
これを現在1どういうふうにやってい
早いのでクローズドいいっ
アメリカと言えるも今携帯電話伊那市
1回の時代グラボっ
簡単に実は現金を送金できるような
そういったのを買え
私たち取り入れました回収するときに
モバイル用
回収をしている
そうすると何がいいんだっ
あの人が現金回収しているから嫌われん
泥棒だっ
阿部見合う
まだこのをチェックする日本人みたいでね別に管理できたいんですけど
なかなかありが人があった
関数というのは
難しいのか
それでもサポートするのがセクゾン
こういったところでアメリカ版携帯は
風を務めています
活動して3分の
ません
今
の2月立ったり客世帯での give するおくことができます
ただまた
まだだっ
どんな所で色が濃いなっちった曲
たところにこれからの展開をしていたいっ
私がこの活動を通じて学んだことを持とう
お伝えしたいと思います
自分の自分
そして応援される力を月
分自身変更でようであっ
そもそも私こういう戦場で発表するように大家で
同期かといったひっこみじように誰か大工のを築いていける
そんな私なんですけど
学生時代人分まだペルサでボランティアしたのが一番最初のボラン
私はまだ学生だったので薬剤師の杭
か
なんですけれどもこんな私でも誰かよくに立つことができるんだ
のボランティアね
のカラッ
ボランティアになさった
ただ短期のボランティアだという
自分がやってがとか本当にらかに立ってるのか
にそこで平気で考え
アフリカのん
けれどもここでまた食べ
おや大反対です
諦めること思っ
言われたんです
子供戦争6位立っ
私は何では肉どうしてるんだろう
フェイスカラー
涙が多い
ます顔で泣いた
なんですけど
2ヶ月親千束
時間使えます
連合に入ってくれた
それがをやめちゃおっ
この反対があってよかったなと思います
本当に空気が何かりっ
終わりません
これを乗り越えたらアフリカでもいろんな問題点があります
乗り越えることがあった
雨が2年間を超えてきました
先にまたうんち出て来ちゃ
何か人に行ってあげようと思ったら
自分の沐浴スキルを高めないといけないということ
3うちになっ
もう一つ
マネジメントうちからを受けなければからませ
私のうん
はいとた人は
元マネジメントスキルが必要だった
そして大学院の方に向かっています
テーマとしては医療アメリカの医療の改善を
天宮をスタートします
そこで考えたのが起きるすみません
ただをモデル本当にそれでいいの
1回ゼロの場合もない
キャップのビジネスモデルを考え
そこから自分からやりたいこと
を
それがブンブンできるのかんと思いを絞って言って
[音楽]
スタートしましたか
実際に
大学院電波た者
その後様々な人だから
30人ほどのメンバー
ただこの程度区3文
いろんな問題でい
まだ自分の体調を崩しました
ベットから起き挙げられないんですよ
これがて起き上がるような
アルマンです
またこの組織を立ち上げただけ
妊娠していることが理由
私の母親としてません
組織のトップとしてません
これがぶつかり合っ
私はどうしたようなもの
それを支えてくれたのが下図である
諦めから終わりだよ
家族その言葉が私はて
七海バーの声ガード
そのおかげで今は
腰痛戦後土曜育てる
俺団体と市の一緒なんですけど
私の人生年なんでしょうけど
今まで様々な空気電池や
でも今は大きな一歩道が上の前います
朝は自分が天候でようないこと
そしてアフリカ日本
2200円
これから本当に
タイでも命を作れる
ありがとうございます